Where does the campy 1966 "Batman" movie fit
in among the grim and gritty "Dark Knight"
films of the 21st century?
Keep watching, because the answer awaits!
You could make a case that 2005's "Batman
Begins" is a more practical starting point
for a neophyte than 1989's smash hit "Batman"
by director Tim Burton.
There's a solid basis for that argument, and
it has to do with character motivation.
In 1989's "Batman," eventual Joker Jack Napier
murders young Bruce Wayne's parents in front
of him.
Traditional versions of Batman's origin depict
nervous, incompetent, anonymous mugger Joe
Chill gunning down poor Thomas and Martha
Wayne.
That might sound like a trivial change, but
it actually makes a significant difference:
By removing the randomness and mundanity from
Batman's foundational violence and attributing
it to a major supervillain, Burton makes Batman's
vendetta about a specific evil dude rather
than the abstract concept of crime.
So why is 1989's "Batman" the place to start?
It's simple: this version set the standard
for the plethora of superhero blockbusters
to follow.
Between its record-breaking box office returns
and the corresponding merchandising bonanza
that followed, "Batman" was everywhere during
that final year of the '80s.
We are still feeling the ripples its enormous
splash left in the cinematic marketplace.
Thus, it makes sense to watch this "Batman"
before "Batman Begins," because without the
former, the latter would have never been made.
If you start with 1989's "Batman," then your
best bet for sustained continuity is the path
laid out by the '90s Batman movie timeline.
That makes your second stop Tim Burton's follow-up:
1992's "Batman Returns."
This sequel marks Michael Keaton's second
outing as the Caped Crusader and also boasts
Michelle Pfeiffer and Danny DeVito delivering
quintessential performances as Catwoman and
the Penguin, respectively.
With its dark fairy tale aesthetic and emphasis
on damaged outcasts, "Batman Returns" probably
has more in common with other Tim Burton projects
like 1990's "Edward Scissorhands" than most
other superhero movies.
It's certainly too macabre for small children,
which is why there was such a huge backlash
after Warner Bros. deployed misleadingly kid-friendly
marketing, including McDonald's Happy Meals toys.
But as long as you keep the kiddies away from
this flick, you'll have a great time.
You will, however, notice a major departure
in tone once you move on.
Burton and Keaton both left The Caped Crusader
behind following "Batman Returns," and the
decision-makers at Warner Bros., rattled by
the backlash, decided Gotham City needed to
get a lot less gothic.
A more accurate title for 1995's "Batman Forever"
might be "The Bright Knight Returns."
Fans have been describing Joel Schumacher's
[SHOO-mah-kur] pair of Batman movies as torturous
viewing experiences for years.
They're certainly a lot more colorful and
less serious than either Burton movie — and,
as a certain cultural critic once asked,
"Why so serious?"
1995's "Batman Forever" was a commercially
successful film, though reviews were mediocre at best.
It is also utterly consumed by the all-encompassing
black hole of kinetic absurdity that is mid-'90s Jim Carrey.
Fresh off mega-star turns in 1994's "Ace Ventura:
Pet Detective'' and "The Mask," Carrey's relentless,
rubber-faced Riddler devours this movie, much
to the chagrin of co-star Tommy Lee Jones.
Carrey told Norm MacDonald that Jones was
very upfront about his disdain for him.
"He went like to hug me, and he said, 'I hate
you!'
And Jones wasn't the only cast member having
a rough time.
Effectively immobilized by his heavy Batsuit,
Val Kilmer left the Batman franchise after
"Batman Forever" in order to work on movies
where he got to act instead of just fill a
rubber costume.
Still, "Batman Forever" is entertaining, and
an important step in the Dark Knight's cinematic evolution.
Notably, it marks the first time Bruce Wayne's
introduction to Dick Grayson is captured on
the silver screen.
While the movies are more expensive and, in
theory, designed for a broader audience, the
most influential version of Batman from the
'90s is undoubtedly "Batman: The Animated Series."
This 1992 cartoon takes its tonal cue from
the Burton films while presenting a thoughtful,
emotionally mature, kid-friendly iteration
of Gotham City.
So why did Warner Bros. think they had to
make Batman a grinning goofball to appeal
to children when their own TV show, based
on the same intellectual property, made a
strong case to the contrary?
Who knows.
But we live with the result: 1997's "Batman
and Robin."
"Batman and Robin" combines the intellectual
development of "Mighty Morphin Power Rangers"
with the camp of the 1960s "Batman" TV show,
but - not as good as either.
Basically, the plot entails George Clooney's
Batman almost breaking up with Robin because
Dick Grayson is visibly pushing 30 and makes
no sense as a "Boy Wonder."
Meanwhile, Arnold Schwarzenegger, occupying
the villain spot as Mr. Freeze alongside Uma
Thurman's Poison Ivy, deploys a deadly array
of absolutely terrible ice puns.
It is groan-worthy.
It is tiresome.
But if you get some friends together who are
down to laugh at a low point in Batman's history,
it can be pretty fun to hate-watch.
After "Batman Forever" and "Batman and Robin"
have conditioned you into processing a campy
Caped Crusader, you should be more receptive
to the wholesome hijinks of Adam West and
Burt Ward in 1966's "Batman: The Movie."
Essentially a feature-length episode of the
1960s television series, this flick is defined
by a massive villain team-up: The Joker, the
Penguin, Catwoman, and the Riddler are all present.
"Batman: The Movie" also includes Shark Repellent
Bat Spray, a dehydration device that reduces
its victims to powder, and a sequence in which
our hero declares,
"Some days, you just can't get rid of a bomb!"
While there are certain rules Batman always
has to follow to remain a coherent character,
adhering to grim humorlessness and brutality
are not necessarily among them.
If the Joel Schumacher films are bad, it's
because they rely too heavily on commercialization
— not because they let Batman smile every
once in a while.
The mid-'60s live-action Batman endures as
a positive example of a family-friendly Bright Knight.
Galvanized by a need to course-correct for
the empty-headed neon flamboyance of "Batman
and Robin," Warner Bros. tapped Christopher
Nolan — then known for directing psychological
thrillers like 2000's "Memento" and 2002's
"Insomnia."
With Nolan at the helm, they would pull Batman
back to his gritty, street-level roots.
2005's "Batman Begins" marks the start of
a new timeline: Events that unfold in the
Burton and Schumacher movies never occurred
in this iteration of Gotham City.
Christian Bale's Bruce Wayne transforms from
self-destructive rich kid to ninja trainee
to terrifying urban protector with nary a
Bat-credit card in sight.
The performatively immortal Raʼs al Ghul
doles out his master plan more like a megalomaniacal
Bond villain than any literal or figurative
clown.
The closest thing to camp comes in the form
of Scarecrow: a living haunted house prop
with a vicious streak.
Scarecrow steals his share of scenes in "Batman
Begins."
He could've been the breakout Gotham villain
of his generation had it not been for the
arrival of an even more deranged update of
a Batman enemy in the follow-up film.
If you're going to watch just one Batman film,
it should be 2008's "The Dark Knight."
Not only is this thematically rich sequel
to "Batman Begins" widely considered the greatest
Batman movie, but many believe it's the best
superhero movie of all time.
Christopher Nolan — along with brother Jonathan
Nolan and prolific screenwriter David S. Goyer
— delivers a psychological action thriller
for the ages.
Heath Ledger set the precedent by which live-action
supervillains continue to be judged.
Christian Bale, Maggie Gyllenhaal, Aaron Eckhart,
and Gary Oldman crank out stellar performances
as well, though they're all instantly overshadowed.
Ledger's Joker is simply too spectacular to
be ignored.
"You want to know how I got these scars?"
Tragically, and famously, Ledger passed away
at the age of 28 before "The Dark Knight"
was released.
He went on to win the Academy Award for Best
Actor in a Supporting Role for his work as
The Joker.
In order to examine 2012's "The Dark Knight
Rises" for what it truly is, we have to push
a mountain of critical discourse aside.
Every possible opinion about "The Dark Knight
Rises" has been debated at length.
Is it the best Batman movie ever?
Is it the worst Batman movie ever?
Is it in between?
The fact is, anything following "The Dark
Knight" was always going to feel like a tiny
bit of a let-down.
If you accept that, however, you'll realize
this film has a lot to offer.
Bale is as strong a Batman as ever, going
out on a definite high note.
As for the villains, Anne Hathaway adds a
world-weary sense of snark to Catwoman's classic
moral ambiguity that works like gangbusters.
And then there's Bane.
Tom Hardy's genuine presence as the masked
baddie is irresistible, even if you can't
always understand what he's saying.
Generally speaking, most people agree that
Joel Schumacher's version of Batman wasn't very good.
Most people also agree that Christopher Nolan's
version of Batman was very good.
But there's no consensus on the most polarizing
Batman of all, as tons of fans both love and
hate Zack Snyder's take on the Dark Knight.
Whatever your personal take on Batfleck happens
to be, it's safe to say 2016's "Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice" is where the Caped Crusader
gets real weird.
After observing that Superman can level an
entire major city whenever he feels like it,
Batman devises a plan to put the Man of Steel
in the ground.
Or maybe Lex Luthor manipulates Batman into
going after Superman?
We're still not entirely clear on the plot
of "Batman v Superman," which received infamously
terrible reviews.
What is clear is that Ben Affleck is doing
his best to play a Batman who has lived long
enough to become the villain.
If your purpose in this endeavor is to watch
every Batman movie, then the 2017 edit of
"Justice League," overseen by director Joss
Whedon, and 2021's "Zack Snyder's Justice
League," the re-edit released on HBO Max,
both do the trick.
These two films tell essentially the same
story and are equally relevant to Batman's
overall place in the pop cultural universe.
But if time isn't a factor, since the "Snyder
cut" is literally twice as long as Whedon's
two-hour "Justice League," we think even the
most adamant Snyder critics would probably
admit his take is better.
Whedon's film has its moments, but it ultimately
amounts to a bland exercise in pushing a handful
of intellectual properties through the market-demanded
motions.
Meanwhile, the Snyder cut is a maximalist
cataclysm of R-rated action-fantasy lunacy.
2017's "Justice League" is a corporate product;
it is not art.
The Snyder cut is also a corporate product
... but maybe it is art?
Either way, one thing is absolutely certain:
there's definitely more Batman stuff in the
Snyder cut, just as there is more of literally
everything else.
"The Batman" opened to generally positive
feedback and appears as though it will more
than likely produce a sequel or two.
However, for right his second, it's a provisionally
standalone film whose identity within Batman's
film oeuvre has yet to fully take shape.
But even though it's the most recent movie
and thus logically the last one you should
watch, there are actually a few different
options for placement of "The Batman" in your
movie marathon.
From the standpoint of its central character's
evolution, "The Batman" could fit before the
Burton/Schumacher series.
Though it's not an origin story in the traditional
sense, Robert Pattinson's depiction of Bruce
Wayne is a hero who's a little underbaked.
He only starts growing into a hyper-competent
crime smasher resembling the guy from 1989's
"Batman" at the movie's conclusion.
Then again, since culture and world events
of the 2000s heavily inform Nolan's trilogy,
maybe it makes more sense to watch the movies
in their real-world release order, as "The
Batman" director Matt Reeves infuses sentiments
of the 2010s and early 2020s into his Gotham
City saga.
We do not recommend watching "The Batman"
immediately before or after the 1966 "Batman"
because the tonal clash between Paul Dano
and Frank Gorshin's interpretations of the
Riddler may cause the viewer some internal
whiplash or psychic damage.
Gorshin's Riddler never successfully kills
anybody, while Dano's Riddler kills a whole
score of folks in nasty ways.
No word though on how Tommy Lee Jones feels
about either of their performances.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Batman
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.